okay so hi everyone we're super excited
to have Elena here I think Elena needs
no introduction amongst this group she's
gonna tell us about sitting in this new
work which i think is pronounced Jessica
I say yeah take it away Elena thank you
very much thank you know for an amazing
and for the introduction so I'll be
speaking about the work we've done
together with Martin with Leo with Iman
with Scottie and with Marc and I guess
half of the coasters are now the
participants and please feel free to ask
questions during the talk I guess I
could see it chat or no one will tell me
about your question so oh it'll be about
so I was trying to structure my talk
such that it's not too trivial so I
won't be really introducing the like the
basics of saving and judging from the
list of participants the majority of you
will know the the basics but rather what
we've implemented in the in this Jessica
saving project and why which design
choices were made so okay this is a
lattice talk and I want to start with
the lattice and this will be like the
simplest the simplest slide so I need to
introduce the problem the problem we're
solving is the shorter Spector problem
so given your lattice which is given by
a basis we want to find a short vector
in the slightest
so typically we don't know how short the
vector will be but we have a rough
estimate of when to stop our algorithms
and this rough guesstimate is you should
have given by the Koski bound although I
will mention later the determination
conditions for for our algorithms may
actually differ from just the length of
the object
and like as you can see from the middle
Skybound it's it's the dimension that
determines the order the rank of the
logistic determines the the the the
length of the expected shortage data and
also the determinant or the volume of
the lattice so to get more specific the
lattices we are usually working with and
these are the lattices that are for
instance given in the lysis challenges
these are the rest is for which we know
the determinant and for instance like in
the lattice i.e the basis for which I
brought on the slide is the lattice that
has on the first column only one nonzero
element which is a big prime P and the
rest is just the identity matrix with
the XS which are uniform random elements
from 0 to P minus 1 and this light is
under some definition looks random and
we know that the determinant of this
edges is is B so and that's that's also
why we know approximately when how short
vector standard such as a star but also
we are not going to be super strict in
the in finding t shortest vector will
also be fine if we are slightly longer
than the e then what we expect to be the
shortest one and by slightly longer we
could be fine with some constant
approximation cost of being one or one
point something one point something to
the to the main cost estimate what I
also want to say the preliminaries is
the definition of perhaps many vectors
or particular atlases because this is
what we are going to use in in our
algorithms so since our religious is
given by a basis so it
the shorter presentation what is also
interesting is another another
representation of the status meaning the
grumpies basis and the Grameen basis is
a set of vectors which are original by
b.i stars and this be my star is just a
projection of the eyes basis vector not
on the subspace orthogonal so the space
you know it'll be the first I minus one
basis vectors so in the example below we
have that is generating by P 1 P 2 and P
1 and P 2 star is it crumpit basis and
Vito star as you can see is the
projection of B 2 orthogonal to the
space orthogonal to the to the line
generating baby 1 and if we do this
projections for all the basis but we
obtain what's called the gram-schmidt
basis and the reason why I'm talking
about it is that because it's often
convenient to represent lattice vectors
in both bases in the in the given basis
P 1 BN and the gram-schmidt basis just
because very many operations and
lattices are actually concerned with the
increment pastes so this is basically
all we need from lattice theory to
actually explain the algorithms and the
main algorithms we implement it I
realized in the in Jessica are the
following algorithms so we have the
exact SVP and the exact recipe is
basically the out an algorithm and
implementation of SVP that compares the
output against the Gaussian eristic or
the Gaussian eristic multiplied by its
constant
1.1 or something around
another thing that the simple Emeritus
was called her - VP this is as I said a
good approximation to the e/m so they
should accept a problem in particular
this is what what is asked to solve by
Downton as it be challenges a pan also
run be kissed at a book block wise
reduction and as a bonus point you can
also run the bliss over that downloads
an illiberal a child challenge again the
doctor challenges up creates inaudible
in lattice and souls and tries to find
the unique short short vector in this in
this lattice so I will not be talking
but I'm just curious should I think of
these is just sort of like different
interfaces to the same algorithm or so I
think of these as like completely
different algorithms these are really
the interfaces that we realize so under
the hood these these three algorithms
will be actually calling either of the
following four sieves
so you're right this will be just
different different interfaces indeed so
these are the interfaces atoms that I'm
describing I'm not sure if this is
completing their bases but these are the
most interesting ones so as I said all
these algorithms they internally call
one of the SVP solvers and sob solvers
that really interested in are saving
solvers so in particular the sealing
algorithms that are implemented at the
following for this is negative then
going with exe or just an receive for
for for the purpose of the talk the
codename bgj one that stands for beca
gamma shoe with one level of bucketing
and that will be clear from what I will
describe later and the Triple C and the
last two algorithms namely
jiwon and triple safe they are
implemented in both single and multi
threaded fashion and actually the it's
sick from the implementation point of
view they they have what they they do
that they do differently single most
effective limitation at least of the
triple safe alright so what I want to
explain next is the last three
implementations of deceiving Proteus
name didn't want me to see if the PDG
one safe and the triple safe I will not
be describing the girls safe because I
think this is I mean what is important
is the last three I mean the house is
also important but Tyrell I choose to
explain the last three so what does then
go and get exceed then kinetic sieve is
simple just to make sure that everyone
understands the sieve this is about
sampling lots of lattice vectors in a
large list and sometimes I will be
calling the list aid list and sometimes
I will be calling this a database we
called it and as a database in the paper
and it means the same thing so to be
more specific about the sampling the
something can be done variously like
when we describe the algorithms usually
we say oh you just take the random
linear combinations of the bases you
could be a little bit more specific
about it and in particular what what is
done in the in the sampling routine is
you could sample the last coordinates of
your fresh vector with respect to the
ground speed Vedas and try to lift the
obtained vector in the sub lattice to
the full lattice by using for instance
papa papa by lift sir you could also
think about doing something more clever
than by by by trying
so sort of spent a bit more time on
sampling it trying to sample short
vectors immediately but currently we're
not doing this traders over here so
something's something that we have our
efficient satellites and this is the
default sampler another default sampler
another possible sampler would be to if
you have already a long list of vectors
you could just try to combine for three
not three 3 would be a bad idea four
five six vectors from your list to
create something shorter and call it a
fresh so once you once you once you
sampled many vectors you put them into
database and you start searching for
pests and this is the main routine when
you start searching for parasitics and y
such that the sum or the difference is
small
and how small is determined by a tunable
parameter and basically whenever I say
small in my talks more is that this is
up to the designer to decide when small
is small and the choices that are
currently done are based music and
experiments and like this should be
smaller than the for instance the
production is considered to be valid if
the result is smaller than the then is
smaller than how should I put it at a
certain threshold and a certain
threshold depends on the on the lengths
of the lists in the lengths of the
vectors in your lists like for example
if it is shorter than the EEM then the
tenth last element in the list in the
sorted list then it's a good reduction
if it's not then it's that's not sure so
once you find this this small sum
difference you put it into the list and
the difference between what is usually
explained in the literature and what is
implemented is that we do not replace X
on Y but we replace the longest chapter
in the list
this may introduce some dependencies but
we don't care about them so my
dependencies I mean there could be
collisions because if you could just if
you could continue if you had fewer
vectors you could you would have found
in the same reduction again and try to
reduce X plus y with X plus y you will
get zero but it doesn't matter once we
have enough vectors all right so
and you continue when you repeat that
you find the next short sum and you
replace the current one was to act
around early so here you replace like
the next position and so on and so forth
until you get enough short pass and if
you continue this for and if you start
replacing enough factors you will
immediately you will soon see that you
have short enough vector in your in your
list so what I should also say here is
the determination conditions in the
algorithms that we implement they
actually differ from just finding a
vector that is shorter than a threshold
simply because what what turns out to be
more important in in practical saving is
that it's not treating the lengths the
only want short vectors but rather the
saturation of your of your space with
many short vectors which is more
important so and if you start to
actually run this algorithm you will see
that you would need that many vectors in
your database and this is actually quite
accurate so if you if you run a
collagenous dimension you will actually
see that the asymptotics are in terms of
memory quite good quite correct and the
running time will be is the square of
the resize also here I should
immediately analytic see if I should
explain or how we actually search for
closed pairs so basically all the time
we'd switch repairs all this algorithm
is doing this it searches for it checks
whether the sum or difference of the
vectors is sure and the standard way to
do this is to check they the inner
product so you live in a product is
large then they are likely to give us
the reduction if not then it's unlikely
that they will give us a reduction so
basically the whole point of the sealing
is to improve the inner product
mutations and one way to do so and this
was already proposed in previous works
is to compute the scalar products
approximately and because of the way
saving works most of the scalar products
will be actually useless and what is
more even importantly what's more
important is to actually discard those
inner products that are useless and one
clever way to do this is to introduce
some hashes and see how hashes they were
as follows we are going to interview to
store our vectors not only as coordinate
vectors in terms of a basis but also as
they seem hashes with respect to to a
place which we chose at randomly in the
beginning so for example if we have here
is a an example of how we store our
vectors or how we store some hashes all
the vectors like let's say you have four
planes we want me to or three or four
and you associate like half of the one
hyperplane a free one it's one and the
other one is zero so whatever is above
free one is one whatever is below we one
is zero and the same for B 2 is 3 and B
4 so for instance after Y has
coordinates 1 1 1 1 just because it's on
the one side of me 1 on the one side of
me to one side of its 3 and one set of
before and similarly for X so basically
we're checking if this from which side
of the hyperplane x and y leave so this
is kind of a rough what called sensitive
hashing except with this hashes to to
miss so why this is once sufficient well
this is efficient because if vectors are
close it's likely that they would lie in
the same house space well if they are
not close they will give that they will
lie in that will that will be
many half-spaces when they way they
differ so and in in implementation you
notice what is fast what as fast as it
affects or and compute the Hamming
weight so for example for these
detectors if you complete the XOR
because they collide on many ones the
XOR will be close to zero and and has
the hanging weight of the result will be
small however if you take the vectors
that are not so close to each other
meaning that they will unlikely to the
reduction the XOR will be just a random
binary vector whose Hamming weight is
around and half the number of bits and
so these these guys which is discard by
saying we are not going to compute the
complete scalar product with the actual
coordinates but rather see now they they
use so this is kind of a rough sketch
for vectors is implemented for all safe
so I do not only store vectors in thei
with respect to the basis transmitted
basis or just standard basis but also
the the hashes and whatever we do the
check we do is check first question
you're saying that even when you do this
like this I squared running time so you
check all possible pairs but still like
before computing it inner product just
because that's expensive for you you
first use it hop count that cuz it this
process they look like a like from like
a boring asymptotic perspective this is
like a constant factor improvement or
something but the actual children so
here we actually she's trying for really
really fasting and we don't want to
compute the product and the
and the sum of flows but we want to
actually do the bits and the reason
being a thick sort of Countess of Chell
is an instruction on menu processors and
this is fast that's that's all I want
cool yeah so yeah this is about I'm
going to me to exceed and this is about
the very basic hash hashing what about
not so basic ash and not so basic
question is what's done in bgj one the
beauty g'wan does the following thing so
basically it's I'm going to attack CF
and buckets
what is a bucket a bucket is a is
defined by Center X where X is chosen
some randomly from our sample database
from our list of vectors and this vector
X by itself defines the region so here I
just imaginary went from the lattices to
spheres but this is for explanation
purposes it's fun and also it it
approximates very well what's going on
in practice so what happens here is we
take around the negative from from a
list and define the region and by
defining the region I mean we just we
just associate another vectors all the
other vectors from the list with this
chosen dr. s by computing the inner
product and again I mean a second
between inner product and you know first
compute the rough inner product with
some hashes and then compute the exact
one so and this leads us to the what's
called bucketing face or the first phase
of the pgj C is we define a bucket and
we run through the list and associate
with the center X all the Y's that have
large enough in a product - always again
a parameter that we that we could choose
so if I face chosen so what does it mean
that it's that
in a product is large it may mean that
X&Y or ridiculous a reduction in which
case we just do we just reduce the Y and
we put it again at the end of until the
end of the rest but what happens if it
doesn't reduce we do not just discard Y
although it was kind of promising but
not promising enough to give a reduction
we put it into the bucket associated to
X and there could be several such wise
in fact there will be many such wise in
this bucket and all those wise they're
kind of conditioned on the fact being
close to X and conditional effect being
close to X me meaning that means that
they could be also close to each other
and this is what is checked in the
second phase which is called phase where
we actually see the bucket so it ran
through all the buckets were stored of
course we're not doing money for one
bucket but many markets and we check we
now do sort of a naive double maybe is a
matter of point but this definition
doesn't necessarily partition the Y's
some might end up in multiple I can
secreting thoughtful does it matter
that's good that's the good point this
is indeed doesn't partition it could be
that the y ends up in multiple markets
and it could be that it doesn't end up
in any bucket so if it turns out that it
does not it it
focus into many buckets that means that
indeed we chose alpha too big so usually
it's a good idea to to choose its output
such that not many same vectors end up
in various buckets but it's alright if
that happens it's not a big it's not a
good problem so it is true that it
doesn't partition they could intersect
that's that's alright so coming back to
the to the Vatican to the receiving the
bucket face is inside this face to run
through the buckets we look at a g-pack
it and we try to find to find pairs
which are short between those vectors
that are in the back and now the
difference between them don't go in
Redux if is that now we do not run now
we do know to the knife to see if on the
original list but we do the the to see
if inside the bucket which is shorter
which which is shorter than the original
list now I simplistically that would
which was excellent on the end as I said
and simplistically if you do the that
many centers that is enough again it's
impossible to find all the pairs your
running time will increase for the naive
square to this running time and this
kind of the running time you should be
expecting from the current
implementation it's I guess it's really
hard to get this particular running time
for the parameters and for the M for the
experiment that we run just because
there were other improvements that I
will be speaking of some of them later
that will actually affect for the
dimensions we we run this constant but
for large enough and the BJJ one
implemented in the in the in Jessica
should keep this this constant
you know there is a question yeah oh
well I think Leo was just explaining
something to help but yeah I was
wondering like where these numbers come
from like in particular like I guess
they depend on alpha so this is like
optimized for alpha or some correct
correct
this is optimized for precise it's there
is probability so such that all but
exponential small fraction of vectors
will be lost
using that so basically it's just how
you choose alpha such that you cover
such that there is a high chance that
you cover all the paths that will be
closed precisely and this will give you
this this M my assume is like 433 and
over to so it's like some beautiful
geometric constant or something these
other things are just sort of like weird
Optimus optimus constant so do they
that's correct okay no so so that this
will be just yeah so this one 1 4 2 is
really you could compute a different
they want way to compute is the
intersection of the wages and high
dimensions and well this is just a sum
there shouldn't be the sum of that ah I
see okay or maybe not so this is just
the the number of centers times the
bucket size squared yes
so this is basically so the rant I will
go through all buckets and do the sieve
inside the buckets which will be the
buckets I squared
I see a man says alpha is chosen such a
cost of populating a bucket is the same
as searching within so that makes sense
you just the balancing yeah alpha does
the rebalancing that's correct
I thank you Iman and let me finish the
BG g1 was comparing what is the current
best one and the current best one is
what's cool again B D G D held sorry
it's about Rebecca gamma require and far
: the difference between the p2 g1 and
this strategy which is the best
asymptotical asymptotically is that you
do not choose the package center being
random elements from
list but rather they should come from a
good spherical code so X in the past
asymptotic intimidation is not a
legislator but it's unweighted villages
it's a good fear occur code and the
reason it's done is that because you
want you want to make the bucket in face
so they're associating a vector to to
the bucket can be done more efficient in
a more efficient way when X is actually
from a structure spherical code so
simplistically it works but it also
means that during this bucketing face
you shouldn t code run a spherical codes
they are two dimension and they could be
of smaller dimension but this introduced
introduces large overheads and as far as
I know Leo did some implementation of
that but it's not yet included and well
it's it's just expensive to do the
decoding all right so if there are no
further questions about BJJ one see if I
could move to the triple see from this
is the sort of another I'm sorry sorry
sorry I should say about before going to
triple see if I should say bit more
about the way it's paralyzed so I won't
be talking too much about the
fertilization today it's a honestly I
forgot when I really when I look back to
this code couple of days ago after not
looking at it for quite some time I
actually feel good if I we did some
things like that but okay so the
paralyzation is done on the
by distributing the pockets so different
threads will be different but it's
meaning that when they find something
new they they actually so the hard part
of the parallelizing the deceivers that
you actually have to update your list in
a concurrent way while reading is is
it's like free many people do not that
there is no concurrency in reading the
list but writing the list actually
introduced some problems because you
actually in order to write you have to
you have to acquire a lock to do the
writing such that not no other thread
reads or uses the vector that you're
going to overwrite and for that reason
the insertions in all the paralyzation
versions eg g1 or triples if they say I
delayed execute it in chunks and batches
what is often as particularly trivial to
do is sorting and sorting who's done
differently between bg1 and triple sieve
so impede you want the sorting is done
by by choosing the dedicated thread than
just sorting and the other and the other
threads if I remember correctly they
just I mean it's not a better it's not
nothing bad happens if you work with me
with not who's not necessarily fresh
database and well the sorting is
although being complicated but not so
much of a trouble in the implementation
for both p2 g1 and for Triple C so this
is what about pearls paralyzed
PGG one the polarization happens between
the bucket so you distribute the bucket
centers around the working threads
Triple C is if you look at it as a
extension of them going vidiq see
the main motivation for the triple safe
is to reduce the memory because the
whole place that you when you look not
four pairs but four triples you may need
fewer vectors in your database to
actually find reductions you may need
fewer actors but you may need but you
may spend more more time and what it
means if we were to run and go invasive
tree pose that would basically mean
going three times three database in a
search of XY and sent letters whose
sound difference or difference is small
and there isn't a choice of science for
each why is that and again once you find
once you find a reduction you will
replace the longest letter in your
database and again you stop and enough
not pass but triples are found and once
enough longest chapter once enough long
vectors are replaced by shorter ones and
there are some theoretical some
particular results about triples they
that shows that indeed you can reduce
memory at the expense of time it could
be even even more paranoid about Marian
you can generalize this received case if
but for implementation reasons
increasing K for larger than one for
more than three seems to be impractical
well K equals three is seems to be a
good choice to do and the way we do it
is as follows it's a particular go-to
to choose K equals three in the view of
the of the implementation of the PGG
what C and here is y so if you if you
remember what I just explained about the
PG won't see if is that we had two faces
the bucket face at the sea face and the
triple sieve differs in the following
way so because we search for triples
we may allow for a bit more
Schlag in the region alpha and this is
the first sort of change is that because
we are now in triples but my best could
potentially go for larger regions and
again here during the packaging phase
you could hope that that some wise
reduce with X but here it's the one less
likely than then in the BG g1 just
because we sort of been sort of
increased the either region between
princess region because during the same
phase of second phase we do not only
look for pairs within the pockets but we
also look for three reductions and now
the three reductions are done with the
center and two other vectors inside the
bucket so the way that the triples if
this Darren is that your again walk
inside look into the bucket and okay if
there is the reduction you do the
reduction but you could also check if x
and y and y prime give you something
small and of course in my picture it's
unlikely that's like this X it's also
impossible the text white join and y 6
give you a reduction but you should
actually look at the signs so it's more
likely that y 2 y 6 and minus X which is
on the other side of the of the sphere
they will give they might give a
reduction so this so there will be a
choice of sign here that makes sense to
them to ask what we asked for for
something small now in here is the so
also for this Triple C if it is
important that X actually comes from the
list but not from from from the lattice
but not from the a.m. but not for
instance from a spherical code so if X
was from spherical call them this last
check
makin sense and if we can tune the
parameters and by tuning the parameters
and in tuning alpha and deciding what
mean what small means we could actually
interpolate between the two see from
this we see so what I mean by this here
is that it turns out in practical
experiments it's also turns out to be
the case is that if you actually
restrict your memory and you put your
you can control the size of your or your
database of your list so if you list is
as large as is required for the to sieve
almost all the reductions come from this
if from these two reductions so from the
reductions between the two vectors
well if you start decreasing the list
sizes so in memory number of this in
your database you can actually start
saying more moral there's three
reductions and if you go to the to the
extreme memory regime where you where
the triples if the Triple C works you
immediately see that there will be
almost no two reductions but there will
be more through three reduction instead
let up here and this of course
determines the the running time of the
algorithm so um okay I'm not very smart
but I would think that there would be
like a pretty sharp threshold like once
I have too few vectors to like like
fewer than whatever it is for Thursday
and over two vectors or something then I
would basically never see pairs but
you're saying that's actually not true
that actually I'll see a decent number
of pairs even if I go exponentially
below for Thursday and over to so here I
really so what I have been said what
I've been talking here about that show
count of three reductions but not
reductions
but this is also so I think we had a
statistics about two reductions but so
on the next slide I actually have a have
a time memory Trados where you can
actually see that so this kind of this
kind of should answer your question
about how sharp at this and so what you
see on the on the leftmost side is for
response to the to see if this is so the
number of place which you shoot one
point three to the N over two so this is
really for third to the N half I say and
on this side you would see what is
needed for this received so to actually
operate this is on dimension hundred and
so yes so it's that view is that sharp
it's right I think I see like that wrong
yeah like you're okay with like
exponentially small fraction of the
pairs being working right okay sorry
okay that's good so yeah as I said we
can the triple see before the trip was
even here on the trip was if you could
actually find more reductions that Josie
if so you would try to play with with
the list and it turns out that
exactly is a selection make sense to
decrease the list and also if you target
if you're a student in your memory for
instance you you'll see that for
practical experience actually need quite
a lot of RAM you could consider random
tripping sieve provided you don't have
enough RAM okay
so paralyzed Joseph is again paralyzing
is done by special the buckets again
rating is lock free there's insertions
are done again in batches but there is a
there is still a big difference within
triple7 pgj won't see if in the sense
that the trip was actually in the way it
treats the the data the database the
list it's more like a like a Gaussian
going media so it actually considers the
database the pair when there is a list
and the parent which is a Q and the Q
which is contains vectors that were
reduced and are about to be inserted
into the list and so on so for someone
kind of go into the details it's really
not a not a very intuitive way to do
this but so the triple the main point is
that the trip was if it's also paralyzed
by two different buckets and the in
assertions should be treated with with a
bit more care as well as sorting so if
there are questions regarding the the
internals of this week it's all worth
it's a good time to ask me these
questions because now I want to move to
the part of the of the talk where
actually do not consider this actually
go to what we actually doing with this
with receiving algorithm business
implementations of the sieves no no
questions I will continue
I have one more dumb question so if I
understand correctly the reason that K
equals three is so convenient is because
for both K equals two and K equals three
you only have to iterate through pairs
of vectors inside direct correct correct
so this is just the yeah so this is just
a convenient way to do seating inside
the bucket or the bucket is actually
labeled by the register C and somehow
like that the general function is just
like either to like the maximum of 2 or
K minus 1 or something's like you never
get any benefit from any other K that
seems like that yeah weird cool okay so
whatever what is done apart from just
ICP solvers so the way you could treat a
super selection quite quite interesting
what you can do with that and the
framework is also the the the ideas that
are implemented in the in Jessica they
should include many previous and the
introduced a new improvements receiving
practical improvements pursuing and I
want to mention three of them and I will
explain in the next slide what what each
and every one of them mean so the first
one's called progressive progressive
receiving and it was introduced
independently by Leo by malaria and
Patel's two years ago and that means
that progressive searing so you don't
have to start with to see if and in the
full dimension what you can do is it but
maybes try to see from the lightest of
all assemblages of smaller dimension and
somehow use this this database of short
vectors but but they'll even sublattice
to actually improve the sieve of the
province even the in Heidemann
analyze the damage of a fridge for free
trick is is you told you know that okay
maybe I should not actually see if and
my full full lettuce again but maybe a
once I see for the projected sublattice
and then I all the sectors Italy for the
particular watches their short enough
maybe they buy buy lifts will open bar
by leaves to the fool to the fool that
ice will give me something short because
if the hope that something short and a
full lattice has a projection it is also
short not much you could also - the
opposite direction it is true and what's
also interesting what's implemented in
the in the framework Jessica is the pic
is that algorithms of block-wise
reduction that does not use SP solar as
a black box
so because saving outputs not only one
shortly after but possibly many short
vectors it doesn't make sense to
actually recycle the short vectors in
between they pick is that the big is
that wrote the big is that routines of
calling the SVP and again a little
change of this in the next slide so
behind all of this improvements there
are there are sort of basic principles
of how to you see if in the how to use
the output of C for the internals of
sieve in the optimal way what we see
think is up to and the first one is
textual notice that C forward puts many
short vectors but not only one and what
is also important to understand is that
we do not really try to find one short
vector but you want to find a short many
short vectors and within the run we try
to improve the quality of the basis
rather than just our put in one short
vector and the quality is measured
it's not surprisingly in the lengths of
the projectors of your bases so in order
to get sorry you're saying that like
when you run you're sitting you don't
just and you're inside bkz you don't
just update the first vector in a block
of size K you update like all K vectors
so so what I'm saying what I would say
but because it is the following so once
you do that once you do see if in the
projected sub lattice that's a projected
sub lattice from I to J and then what
the big is and does it then it goes then
it moves from whether J to I plus 1 J
plus 1 and what makes sense is to read
is to lift the I plus J context into I
plus 1 J plus 1 constant and hope it's
still short which is true it's kind of
short and then you don't start from
straight but you rather but you rather
on to see from this new vectors is what
I want to say and this is again like I
guess this only really saves you like
maybe a factor of n or something like
this but like in practice that's a big
deal it's really hard to say how large
it stays in terms of the quantity M but
yes as much as it seems to be helping
it seems to work well to do I think cool
right so let me so let me tell you a bit
more in detail about the first three
about the progress of seeing the
dimensions were free and the big is that
in a bit more in a bit more detail so
for that I just need one more just to
make sure we you understand my notations
meditations of the projected lattice
will be the following I'm saying that
returning birth to my G so picture is
that I will be denoting by NIJ their
seminal projection of the first of the
lattice generally before the first J
vector R so vanillin to the subspace so
subspace orthogonal to the first
so for example this will be ad - and
alleged' should be should be sort of as
Li but it's lighter so Frank J minus I
plus and with this notation such as
standard notation from the milettis s we
could define a CPC in a sort of non non
black box manner and sort of the main
feature of the of Jessica the kernel the
dream of the algorithm piment it is we
kind of play in between this and between
the several set of instructions that
move from one projected subjects to
another projected sublattice so for
example what you could is you could lift
short vectors from one sub lattice
project as a budget I J to another sub
lattice I plus 1 J for where I prime is
less than I so meaning you just so that
means you just project one on vector up
so you just need so previously you are
projecting to orthogonal e from 1 to I
minus 1 and here you project orthogonal
it'll or 7 also want I minus 2 as you
kind of lift up using by by theta for
instance what is also done during the
SIF routine is that we year try to
update the current basis with
particularly good lifts so if you do
this if and you kind of start with
what's called in on-the-fly lift you
lift it up to the whole to the full that
is and see if it's good or not and if it
is not you could insert you could update
your current basis and all of this is
the operations on the on the on the
lattices could be described by a small
set of instructions so moving from one
projected serviced another projected
services could be done by either
which is just a papaya lift meaning that
you you just just lift up using bye-bye
you couldn't you could run inclusion
meaning that you move from IJ to IJ plus
one so you just add one more vector to
you to your current projected basis and
projections is it posit you just project
out one one vector so you increase the
dimension of your current what is by one
and just let me explain me with this
with these instructions with four
instructions what what could be done
within the the framework just repeat the
instructions so you could see what they
mean the progressive saving the process
of saving meaning that you just you do
not start on the full dimensional
lattice but you start sub lattices is is
nothing but the iterator receive in the
projected services hey I am for
decreasing mice so first you start with
something that is it's just one
dimensional so it's orthogonal to
everything but one then you just add one
more dimension and just another third
dimension and so on and so forth
each time you start not from scratch but
each time you already see in the
lightest on which for which you received
on the sub lattice and this kind of code
[Music]
this thing does so it's kind of a
pre-processing you know it could you
could think about is a pre-processing
step for the next sieve the second
improvement that that's also relevant
for practical thing is the is dimensions
for free where you do not see if until
the very end you stop this
progressive saving maybe not when I is
equal to 1 because when I is equal to 1
you're in full that is but maybe when I
is somewhat close to 1 but not so much
so in that case you could never did in
his you're a [ __ ] 2018 paper is he shows
that if you stop in the N over Logan
dimensions before you had so you would
need an overlooked in dimension more to
get to the fool that is you're already
good enough to sort of lift up with Baba
lift your short vectors in this lattice
to to get a good chances to have good
chances to obtain something short in the
full lattice so this is kind of this
general Ogun factor it could remind of
pruning factor for the for the
enumeration algorithm spike in in the
nature it's it's different but in terms
of quality that it brings it is similar
and you can also see that in practice at
it also we we do not for the for the
challenges that were self that were
solved is it was not necessary to
surround the see from the full edges and
the big it'd not be another instructions
that's that were that were sort of
realized and implemented in the in
Jessica is what's called pump pump is
just a set of instructions that runs
progressive sieve from from a small a
small dimensional edges one to n minus I
plus 1 and doing this progressive sieves
it updates the basis by inserting them
this shortly after since into into the
basis and also using this pump you could
have you could cops could work out is
that's it's a click you see this
progressive sieve for for decreasing
eyes so you just
you just insert you're just trying to
progress yourseif not for i before i
minus 1 and then i minus 2 and so on so
do this pre-processing with each
dimension in vice and so all of that you
could also using all of that you could
run big easy
so b gets the block wise a reduction and
just let me tell you a couple of more
words about how the big how big is it
it's done in the in jessica so the
simplified version of the plane because
that is here you have you call SVP
oracle on the peter dimensional that is
projected lettuce dimension be done and
once you find something short in this in
this goes to SVP your databases by
inserting what you found and it's a new
remove some linear dependences so if
you're giving an n-dimensional basis you
run as 50 on the beta dimension then you
move these from 1 to B 2 to 2 Peter plus
1 and so on and so forth what you could
do if you run SVP not so if you're not
oblivious to what is repeaters in
particular if you're SVP is a is a
sealing algorithm you might as well want
to reuse not only one vector which is
sure but also many vectors as a short so
in particular you could rewrite the
because s algorithm by just calling the
see if on the on this note on these kind
of lattices and by noting that each time
you do that you're kind of you have an
inclusion of the assemblages if so once
you once you're good here
once you increase your dimension so this
progressive sieve you you're already
good
you give your hope to be not so bad in
the in the in the slightest and also
once you sort of move back once you move
your con
from k k plus beta 2 k plus 1 k plus
beta plus 1 the point of this is that as
explained in previously you could just
so what it means you just you you lift
up in one dimension and you project back
into the other dimension so basically
you're like you're two dimensions away
in your context and if you were sure and
if the beat is long enough large enough
which so that gives you the that gives
you hope that this lifting and insertion
leaves you with something short so it
doesn't spoil what you the work you've
done on the previous on the previous run
so
that's that's how you could for instance
you speak is that we see weaknesses
cocaine is a simplified thing
you could check the paper for the for
more detailed version of that but the
idea is so if there are questions for
theory part that would rather take them
now because I have one most couple more
slides about experimental results and
the experimental results that that were
reported and we have been doing them on
which was not the challenges just to
comparison reasons and so this is the
the results by the time we published the
paper this was one here we go it was
previous previous year the the whole
frame and Dunst a challenge so I looked
like that Brock simply the way we
managed to so so we nice to solve ACP in
dimension 155 within Fortune dayson lots
of CPUs well I don't remember how I
don't exactly remember how many threads
we've been using but it could be either
I think it was around 18 and we used
sort of memory so it was a good machine
thanks to maarten we've been using his
machines to run the experiments so as
you can see we we did not have to run
SVP in dimension 155 thanks to the
dimensions for free trick the actual
dimensions we run Zevon was 127 so this
is approximate level of of savings you
could get and these these experiments
were done with BJJ one
I should also mention that it's not the
current best regards if I well I checked
the whole frame today lunchtime so the
contract and they still do Tulio mark
and fasten and they managed to solve
them as 157 and if I remember correctly
this was using GPUs so all the things I
was talking to you was not on GPUs and
CPUs and I don't believe it on GPUs if
you're if you're smart enough you could
probably do more things with GPUs but
this were not GPUs and also this
implementation was not distributed so it
was one machine it was one but good
machine and and yeah we did require
quite some RAM to run it so this by the
way improves the the previous best
record for enumeration that was if I
remember correct it was about hundred
fifty dimension hundred fifty to wayna
this is done with this way like not
exactly triple sieve but like this oh
okay so there's it's just pairs not
triples there's just a speed current oh
and you still match to get the memory
below I guess like 256 gigabytes is
probably a pretty big constraint yeah so
I think that the the biggest experiment
155 we've been running on 512 gigabytes
but here and also I should say it's like
so although I am kind of showing here
the experiments for large dimensions
receiving in this implementation also
improves our enumeration implementations
of FPL not on I mean the improvement
wasn't that dimensions eighty or ninety
I think 18 so kind of the crop this
golden cross cross over point is is
below hundred all right
so I leave my last slide with the with
the link to to the library and was a
link to the paper it's it's open source
it's so the core is intimacy passports
and mmm the the friendly interface has
as Marty likes to say in friendly
interfaces and it isn't matted with
Python you can download it and use just
so you would need a pilot
you wouldn't have dated it for that and
okay I guess I'm good with time for
questions I'd like to thank you for
worried for your attention I take
questions and at the end there at
references to issue which you can find
us online
okay great so that was wonderful let's
uh thank Elena if you can you know
quickly mute yourselves and applaud that
would be great so we're getting better
so if anyone has questions I guess now's
a good time
oh you also have chat applause yeah do
you see the chat I'm opening I'm not
sure no they're just applause right now
but let's see if anyone has questions
okay I have many but I probably
executive questions
Ellen are these
Jessica ingesys on the open source gita
and so on
is there also enough you know a
documentation and examples for people to
easily figure out how to use it or I
mean it has been open source is not and
it can be a big effort for anybody else
to use something so I think it's it's
probably a bit less the community terms
of the manuals as parallel at the moment
but definitely what was done during the
Simon's workshop is Martin was doing
labs and I think it has a pretty good
lab sheets how to install them how to
use Jessica so I guess I'm not sure if
it's online or not with that I'm sure
that if you asked Martin she will put it
online but currently it's so the
instructions how to install is basically
as good as instructions replied in it is
just the first step and I see there are
installation instructions on what you do
with it how do there something that I
didn't try I'm not saying that it's not
there I'm just asking if it's something
that so I guess it depends on which
level you want to actually with it if
you just want to play with the
parameters that we chose this is pretty
simple and the examples are there so you
could just run you could just
essentially receiver as a we can
disassociate this year and run it and
and reap and redo all the experiments
that we've been doing and for all the
experiments that we've been doing there
is actual line of command that you
should input into your machine and you
should recreate the same experiments as
we as we had this is one thing and this
should be simple this should be simple
enough provided that we means that the
information is there now the different
thing that if you want to actually oops
just I just noted it haha I didn't want
to do this but I managed
yes so these okay now since I moved it
they can also show you so yes so they
producing all the experiments that we've
done is is explained in the the github
page so this should be we still see your
slides because oh you shared the window
not this right that's interesting how do
we do it maybe if you stop sharing for a
second amenorrhea uh-huh you share very
good and I can share the desktop now yes
good yes so yeah so basically so how to
reproduce the experiments from the paper
this you can do by just copying pasting
this in the command line what to do if
you want to do the if you want to use
Jessica from poison you can also do that
and by specifying the algorithms
I'll explain here for instance and this
is nothing else but just standard what
is that example these are exactly
examples of what you do to run something
on your own
correct okay and it is on the github on
there okay but what I want to say if you
actually want to change the alphas and
the on the parameters of your of the
safe like the sensitivity of the
shortness the the way you handle the
size of your database so if you want to
change the expiry I should have to go
into into the code now so you have to
recompile them because some things are
actually compiled time constants okay
thanks
so any more questions okay if not let's
attempt to do this clapping thing again
that's okay let me stop the recording